hey guys what's going on welcome to
another python finance and mathematics
video in this video we're going to be
talking about both
highest high and lowest low so some
people like to plot
either just the highest high or just the
lowest low
and or you might see some people that
plot them together so what we're going
to do in this video is cover highest
high lowest low we are going to plot
them together but of course you can use
your own discretion and
choose not to plot them together so what
i've done now hopefully it's going to
help us out
is we can go to that the page
the link is in the description and now
i've got the starting code for the
calculation videos if you click on that
that'll take you to this page and it has
that starting code now so you don't have
to like keep retyping that over and over
um unless i'm sure some of you guys
saved it but this will help some of
you guys are just joining us out so uh
now the next thing that we want to do is
define
um oh and also make sure you have sample
data.txt i suppose i left that out
that's also in that link in the
description here
uh just click on sample data it takes
you here and then save that
at least here we're asking you to save
it as single data.txt
so let's get to the actual function
itself so we're going to define
hh low low for highest high and lowest
low to do this we need the date
the closing price and the time frame we
want to consider
now let me just do this some people like
to do
with the high prices so and then the low
like the highest high of the high prices
and then the lowest low of the low
prices but most of the time you're
actually going to consider
just the closing price of that beach bar
of data
so not always is you know like at least
throughout this series we've done open
high low close
and it's been for like a day right a
whole day
and but generally if you've got like one
minute tick data let's say or take data
one minute you know open high low close
data you've got
still the open high low close there so
it just doesn't really matter like it's
just mostly depending on that bar
and we just so happen to be using one
day long bars
anyway uh so this function is going to
return an
hh for the highest high and ll for a
lowest low
fix this now uh x
is going to equal time frame so that's
where we're going to start while x is
less than the length
of whatever db what are we going to do
we're going to say
the consideration highs is equal to c
x minus tf uh
x and then cons low
equals c x minus t f colon x
so to the x next we're going to say
highest high
equals the max of consider highs
and lowest low equals the min
of cons low
next we're going to say hh dot append
highest high then ll dot append
lowest low make some more space here
all right let me pause or mute my
speakers someone
keeps messaging me now uh
x plus equals one and then finally we're
going to have this return
d for date h for the highest high in ll
for lowest low
finally um it's going to do hhll
date close p and we'll use a 5
time frame now the next thing we want to
do is actually
chart this so if you notice i skip
usually we do like an introductory video
or i explain the thing then we do it
i think highest high and lowest low is
fairly self-explanatory
and simple enough to where i'm actually
going to condense it all into the same
um same
tutorial video as long as i can think of
what i want to say
and actually we didn't have to really do
this but we can run it and we can just
you know kind of print out
uh so we could just say x y z
equals that and then we can print y
print z and that'll be like our actual
output here
uh we did okay we type out a pen there
let's try it one more time
okay so now we got it printing out stuff
that's what we want right we want 57 ish
because we're talking about starbucks
here
so now that we've done that now the next
thing we want to do is actually
chart this up so let me go back over to
where we were and here's this page with
sample code with the empty slot
if you don't already have it click on
that and then
copy and paste that sample code
into an empty python script so let me do
that let me move this thing out of the
way
bring this over paste that code in here
and if you scroll up just a little bit
there's a spot for our indicator so what
i'm going to go ahead and do
is copy and paste uh basically
everything up to the definition of that
function
and then come over here oops that's the
wrong thing
come over here and paste into there
and then we'll do two tabs over and now
i'm actually going to rename this stuff
but first let me fit this to my screen
and now we're going to rename these
i'm going to leave that variable well we
better not i'm going to say
h h l l x h h y l l y
equals uh that then
we're just going to plot these up and
we're going to say ax2.plot
hhl hhllx
hhy and we're going to make this line
green since it's the highs
s2.plot h l l
x h h or no lly
plot it as a red line next we're going
to do the minus s p
colon if you want to know why we're
doing that uh check out the
charting stocks in python tutorial
series i'm going to copy this now
paste paste paste
and then we're going to add our y label
so plt.y
label and this will be hhl5
and we need to make it white so color
equals white
and that should be it so let's go ahead
and save that and run that hopefully no
major errors it's asking us what stock
to plot let's split up starbucks
and okay cool so here's starbucks and we
can see down here is our
high high low low and let me talk about
a little bit about the high high low low
like why people actually seem to like
that one um actually you know it would
be a good idea
we could plot the highest high and
lowest low right on the prices
because i was going to say generally it
smooths out the line
without very much lag
but also it just happens to look like
it's smoother because this is a
different chart right
whenever you make a chart squished like
this uh
it just makes it look less volatile so
so it's kind of uh cheating us a little
bit there so what we could do
is
well i'll talk about that in a second
anyway so people will use this one to
smooth out a little bit but also you can
kind of gauge
um it's like a different way to look at
the prices i suppose um
so like whenever there's like a price
movement generally you're going to see
either the lowest low coming
up right and it's going to push your
highest high up or if it's falling the
highest high is going to be
falling and the lowest low will also
obviously be pushed down because
of it and so it is just kind of like a
way to smooth the lines without
being like really lagging because it's
actually looking at
previous data so a lot of times it's not
going to lag
like a simple moving average so at will
it will we were talking about it let's
go ahead
and um i think i could just change this
to one
and that won't be an issue for us so
let's go ahead and plot it up on ebay
again
nope that was wow it got really angry at
me
uh
i wonder why it got so mad for access
because axis one is the one that
um
oh maybe it's the y label
i don't know um trying to think of why
it would have gotten this angry at me
over that uh
it's it's trying to do something about
maybe the date i can't even like see
what line it's even referencing in this
gobbly mess
wow anyway let's go ahead and just i'm
just gonna
copy this function here we'll replace
this as
two and two hopefully i can do this uh
we'll come up
up here uh the definition since i'm
doing this let me
make my font smaller so i can see what
i'm doing better
uh let's look right here i'm just going
to make some space
tab
i'm not sure sp is defined at this point
though
so this needs to be dtf let's make this
etf colon
so the data matches i think time frame
isn't defined until
later on in the script well actually you
know what i think it's
yeah it's defined already um
okay let's try it again hopefully it
doesn't just go crazy on us otherwise i
have to figure out what
the heck's going on
okay that worked okay so anyway
um let me drag this over i guess because
probably what had happened
is it plotted it and then it formatted
the
the
dates on uh this axis here
and then it and then when i went to
reply on there it was very angry at me
because i was like trying to reformat
again
so that was the issue but anyway um it's
actually kind of hard to see
this so let me zoom in let's zoom into a
like a volatile spot
first so it's it's you know kind of a
way to add bands
around uh your stuff and as you can see
it's somewhat lagging
in you know like the intensity so to
speak
uh but not anywhere near as much as the
lagging
of like the simple moving average like a
10 simple moving average because i think
we were using a 5
for this so we could change this to like
a five and we could see what the
difference is
um but anyway uh so
those are your high highest high and
lowest low lines
um pretty basic indicator
i don't really see the huge value in
having these lines maybe i just don't
understand them
uh which is totally possible but
they are somewhat popular for people to
use especially as a form of
band and then they put like a simple
moving average on there and whenever
it kind of acts as a signal line
basically when this simple moving
average or it either crosses over or the
simple moving average goes
outside of it um that's kind of like an
indication of something but
anyway um wanted to cover them they're
basic enough to cover and i was able to
jam them all into one video so
there you have it so hopefully you guys
enjoyed hopefully you maybe learned
something new not sure
what new things you would have learned
besides the indicator but
anyway hopefully it was enjoyable for
you guys as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support the
subscriptions and until
next time